I have some tour dates to tell you about
I'll be in Washington DC October 22nd
Las Vegas Nevada
October 27 and 28 Norfolk VA November 9
Roanoke VA November 10 and Huntington
West Virginia November 11 at the
Mountain Health Arena formerly the Big
Sandy
get all your tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r thank you for the support we
have a new merch drop we Merchant baby
check out the new be good to yourself
tie-dye hoodies in aqua Indigo and
creamsicle find that and much more at
theovanstore.com also there's a lot of
other bootleg merch out there and some
of it's real neat
um but if it's not from our store just
know that uh we're not the ones doing it
just so you know that
today's guest is beloved in the comedy
community he's an actor he's a podcast
host and he's an endangered species of a
man
today's guest is uh is from the Far East
and we're happy to have him you know him
from Bad friends and tigerbelly today's
guest is Mr Bobby Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah what does that mean he goes it's
half
two a racial slurs in one word man oh
that sounds yeah crazy well it's
uncalled it's uncalled for it dude yeah
and I'm like dude I'm no sugar to you
dude yeah that's crazy and you can say
sugar because you are what it means
how do you can anybody I didn't say it
dude so why do it comes up to me go yo
what's up and I go what he's
like yeah man it's two racial slurs and
one I go I'm not a but Tiger
Woods is you know what I'm saying
dog what's up
man that's out of pocket it's so hard to
be racist these days because of uh
diversity diversity and intermingling
what do you mean what do you mean like
it's always been hard to be racist oh
yeah you know yeah it's always been a
hard thing yeah yeah and it should be I
don't yeah it should never be easy yeah
yeah yeah but if you could do it good
for you dude
what the problem is there's no like
there's no way to win with racism
there's no there's no way to lose either
though that's the thing
you know everybody's like well in
between kind of thing you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
I don't know I don't know either man
sometimes I don't even know dude but you
just do it you know yeah dude I think
the racism that I think is kind of the
safest way if I've seen any to try and
do any racism is I don't even know if
this is like I don't know but you don't
want people doing anything Dangerously
that's the thing about racism dude it's
like for me it's like if there's a you
know a noose or they're gonna drag me in
back of a truck you know how they used
to do that
these are Thai Asians in the back of a
truck and they just drive you know
really yeah give us a ride you know what
I mean like you're like uh like uh like
you're wake skating or something yeah
well it's like a reverse Rickshaw it's
like the white version of a rickshaw
if Comics are being racist yeah amongst
you know we're amongst friends I I like
it but if it's if I don't know you dude
I'm at an airport and you're like what's
up it's like it's like oh I
don't like it at all dude it breaks my
heart dude breaks my heart dude the
saddest thing I think but also the thing
that kind of like
if say like you're hanging out with
somebody right and you guys are
different ethnicities or whatever give
me specifics because okay because
depending that of what kind of ethnicity
it depends on this how I would react
okay say you're hanging out with like a
Muslim guy
all right nah okay we'll say someone
pass
say somebody's hanging out with a Muslim
all right you know let's okay I'm
hanging out with a Muslim and I know a
couple so I'm hanging out with like
Fahim Anwar okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
right
so and somebody Drives By in a truck
right because it's always a truck I
guess it's always a truck and yells out
uh get out the street slim they call
them Slims a lot of times wait wait
they call Muslims Muslims yeah
you mix it up dude never heard anyone go
what's up like after 9 11. those slams
bro they never said that bro people it's
definitely been said that has been you
said it probably a thousand times that's
why and you heard yourself say it and
you're like oh that's a thing I've never
heard slam bro
all right so I'm with if we're walking
down the street okay truck drives by get
off the streets
now here I think we would look honestly
I think we would look at each other go
I think was they talking about me you
know what I mean right or you because
we've never heard slim before okay so we
went both we both absorb it understood
yeah yeah but what I'm thinking is the
best way for any racism occur that it
shouldn't occur it should never occur
right but if it has to occur in the
world
sometimes it has to right is that what
you're saying
look I don't I think a little bit keeps
thing it keeps you know it keeps the
engine running yeah yeah
and let's don't use the term engine
all right well what I'm saying is that I
think
um you the best way for racism to occur
if it has to occur is if somebody drives
and yells it out of her because then
they're gone it's over it happens it's a
drive by racism yes yeah yeah but you're
saying that's okay no I don't think it's
okay but I think it's the safest way
it's the safest way to do it yeah but
then if they do a U-turn
then we got a problem what's up slim I'm
like oh that's yeah they turn around
yeah then we're running yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and we don't even know me
and film we don't even know who they're
talking about but we're both gonna run
just in case you know yeah I don't you
know could I be awesome too man yeah man
you don't have a racist bone in your
body man
I don't think so yeah I I don't think so
either dude I could name a few comments
that may you know I mean they kind of
lean you know I want to name it oh can I
just get on this out of the way bro yeah
I have some resentments not towards you
yeah but toward the community okay I'm
gonna so anyway um what happened well
yesterday was my birthday
so over the weekend you know we me and
bad friends we did some shows we were in
um
click uh one of them white Columbus one
of them places yeah no we're in
Pittsburgh bro oh yeah yeah
so we're doing a show
sorry Facebook boy thank you
mom's gonna get your Playboy
subscription is that Pittsburgh yeah if
you come down from there all right all
right anyway we're in Pittsburgh we're
doing a show half her doing the show
it's my birthday right so then um Andrew
goes um yo dude happy birthday Andrew
Santino from Bad friends
your co-host
honest make sure everybody knows who
you're talking about yeah man we didn't
say his name he said Andrew yeah but I
said anyway oh yeah banjo Santino okay
okay so then he goes um
you know we have happy birthday I got a
birthday collage of people sending in
you know I mean videos oh yeah and I
want to say bro thank you so much you
sending a video dude thank you a lot of
people did John Mayer did wow yeah not
the musician you know that I know got
him John was a mayor at Victorville oh
yeah no the musician that was a bad joke
but John Mayer did right Whitney
Cummings right the little handsome dwarf
he's in the movies what's his name uh
the handsome dwarf uh Adam DeVine no way
yeah dude wow one of the best looking
dwarves I've ever seen better than Peter
Dinklage oh yeah they're not acting
similar but it's just a good looking
dude oh my god dude Divine versus
Dinklage dude that's a show dude or a
movie or something yeah it's like Alien
versus Predator
I wonder how much dangling she's got on
him
that's got to be annoying yeah he won't
say that all the time yeah so there was
a bunch of people sent in videos oh man
except and then afterwards I I looked at
Andrew and go who didn't send one
you know because he requested a lot
I don't want to call anybody out man but
there's a couple that I don't want to
say their names but it really broke my
heart man
let me got requests
and they never sound long can I guess
who someone could be I can give you some
hints okay one hand yeah
one of the guys imagine finding a dead
body in a leg but it's been there for a
month and it's bloated oh yeah it will
be bloated yeah yeah some of the jewelry
too will be like yeah yeah so that's one
of them okay the other one
used to look like that
what Bert
I'm not gonna answer that man
okay the other guy is friends with the
dead body guy who used to look like that
but doesn't and he claims he's hispanic
but you don't see no Hispanic Bloodlines
in his face you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah he's like you know definitely
never said that okay sorry never said
neither neither okay but those are a
couple of guys man that like I thought
they were like
my boys dude and they betrayed me a
little bit like you know you sent a
video it was long
yeah there were some people that I don't
even know that well that's in a video
yeah you know and you know it just goes
to show you who your friends are man oh
in this business
yeah when he says stuff yeah
but you know when we get emotional we do
this dude yeah yeah I mean so it's like
you know you think that like they're
your you know you know those two guys
you know what they're like man you know
what they're like
in a war dude oh you do you ever see
Forrest Gump yeah
remember
the guy was the guy that lost his arms
and stuff oh oh uh no not Dan not Dan
Benedict don't know
he's not I'm not even talking about oh
yeah I remember when who's he saving
when like um for us was running and in
the Vietnam War he was grabbed he went
to go save somebody's life was that him
or was it was the black guy Bubba Bubba
anyway that's a terrible analogy but
these two guys would not run back from
me in a war I feel like if you weren't
an iron in a war let's just make up a
war like okay the war the Serbian Marana
gray Manta gray what's it called but
Wars are going to be sponsored probably
by different so it would be like the
like
like Amazon
war of 2027 or something right and
they're oh you know what dude Amazon
versus the eskimos that's never been
done
there's not a lot of Eskimos I know but
still
if it's cold dude they might win
yeah I don't know it's an icy
environment dude like Hoth like Amazon
versus like who Amazon truck drivers or
something yeah yeah dude Amazon truck
drivers versus Eskimos I mean that could
be a good War yeah anyway you and I are
caught up in it oh yeah right my legs
are gone oh right I feel like you would
go
I think you come back for me dude yeah I
put you on my um on my back
you know putting me on your back like a
backpack yeah
and oh this is my friend backpack yeah
yeah
yeah yeah what I would do with you dude
I would tie a rope to your neck but not
to hang you but I would drag you what it
sounds well all you have to do is put
your hands with where the Rope is so you
can get some oxygen oh yeah it sounds
comfortable yeah yeah so and I would
drag you out my point is it's a terrible
analogies but my point is these two two
fools probably wouldn't even save me man
wow said it really hurts your feelings
a little bit wouldn't it hurt yours well
I think that if Andrew asked everybody I
don't know who he asked you know and did
a lot of uh were most of the did your
did anybody else make a video like did a
lot of your other comedian friends make
them or I'm going to tell you Bobby
Kelly I know I'm okay right he's from
New York I've known him for a very long
time him and I have rekindled our
relationships I really love the guy Bob
oh yeah Bobby Kelly he's sounding one oh
right my brother obviously kalilah
obviously and then who else is Whitney
Adam John Mayer
um
you a bunch of fools yeah but you
know they they were just not in it you
know anyway would you neither so you
wouldn't be sensitive about it oh yeah I
think well it depends like on who they
asked and what was going on if these
people were if they've been ill if
they've been in a hospital if they've
been oh okay going through like a family
thing I don't remember how long ago
Andrew asked me for it I think it was
just a few days ago yeah that's what he
told me and he goes Theo responded so
quickly and that's why
thanks dude
no don't cry brother you know brother
don't cry that really hurt me because I
was so I was laying on the stage yeah
like just watching the video oh and I
got emotional yeah but then of course I
asked but anyway let's move on from it
but you know it's out of pocketed it's
out of pocket god dude and do you feel
like you're gonna how do you pay that
back to are you gonna hold a grudge
because it sounds like you have a
resentment
yeah I do a deep one and guess what what
I'm not gonna with those guys for a
while wow maybe at least a month
one month huh yeah then one month off
that Bobby Lee yeah because you've never
been you've never been in the outs with
me bro
well
oh yeah yeah I forgot I didn't
know the only out's about no I think
after you and your girlfriend broke up I
think there was a moment where you
thought I was gonna try to make a move I
think
and I remember you being a little bit
strange to me I'll tell you what I think
out of all the comments that would have
made a mood that you had the better
chance the best chance to get in maybe
that's what it was thank you I saw and I
did not make a move you would never make
a move not a chance brother I could name
you who did
I'm not kiddingly oh dude
or white
white white the whites do that dude
the blacks don't do that man they don't
they're loyal bro yeah yeah man I don't
know a crypt would never shoot another
you don't think
by accident maybe dude you know a lot of
like Bloods they all they they take c
words and make them start with b you
know that
they're like uh
like we had YG in and he was talking
about uh sexy red and he's like sexy red
going brazy so they say instead of crazy
they say bro it starts with a B wow like
they say I move into bompton like they
won't say that yeah I love that Island
batalina yeah they say yeah that's
pretty cool they put a b in front of
anything yeah so they call
hey man you like my bats
oh yeah pet my back yeah but then when
they actually had a bat with what they
call that uh uh I don't see a brother
with a bag
yeah I've never seen a brother with a
bat I don't you talking about count
Blacula
I don't think we're having that dude
yeah I've never seen that before again
Brothers don't with a lot of
like that yeah bats reptiles
yeah yeah now you'll see at Halloween
sometimes her brother will leave his
weiner out and put a fake spider on it
you know right right and I don't want to
be racist but I shouldn't even said that
yeah but I've never seen a brother with
a cat either though is that true yeah
have you I don't think so I've never
seen her oh damn they need yeah yeah
like you see like old photos of like
yeah of like Marlon Brando was a huge
cat dude
Abraham Lincoln how many cats did Abe
Lincoln have let's look it up yeah yeah
but check it out dude and you think he
freed black people you think one of them
would stop by and pick up a cat
yeah yeah I've never even seen like but
you've never seen Sidney Poitier right
with like a cat dropped wrapped around
his shoulder but maybe if you Google it
I never Google it maybe that's true yeah
you never seen him just petting a tabby
in the sun you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
but he dude if they have an article then
they with them yeah he
was fond of dumb animals especially cats
and tips
are you serious left his dog at home in
Springfield when he went to the White
House and then had cats
unexpected gift of two kittens from
Secretary of State William Seward wow
wow a man giving another man two kittens
is hella it's it's like suck my dick
yeah right that was the 1800s give me a
BG homie you know why don't you go why
don't you duck below that Mason Dixon
yeah
yeah if I give you a kitten dude I mean
what would you do why don't you
emancipate these nuts yeah that's what's
going on uh but that's wild yeah you
don't see and bring up Brothers with
cats man maybe I'm wrong though and I I
I you know I've just never seen it or
Google my black friend with his cat
because you want real images I don't
want stock footage yeah yeah
yo dude all they show is black hats yeah
and blackhead that's oh it is a brother
with a tabby where
right there that's a kid though that's
it yeah oh yeah there we go oh there we
go there we go
one kid
yeah yeah wow yeah
listen listen I you know it's true I
don't wanna I don't want to make
assumptions so that's crazy that I would
even say that no I just said something
I've never seen you know what I mean bro
it's America man it's okay to look at
things and see things you see right you
know
um
yeah dude I would never have uh tried to
slide in your ex are you guys are you
still living with your ex-girlfriend no
she moved on no yeah I didn't no she she
moved a couple of blocks away was it sad
when she moved out kinda
yeah because the house is so dirty now
oh really when you're living with a girl
yeah your house is clean it's like its
own filter like a filtering system yeah
like oysters have that right right right
right but now it's like there's cat
vomit all over the place and the other
day they found maggots yeah dude yeah
how many of them one maggot no they
found a hundreds oh you know what it was
it was like what I do you know what I've
been doing this is so sad I know
it is but you know when the girls lived
up because I had Jewels live there too
and the girls live there you know we
would put out the cat food wet food and
after the cats were done they would wash
it me I just leave out more bowls of cat
food right and then all of a sudden
Jules was cleaning my house and then she
was like she saw one of the and they had
been there for a month
and there was just maggots in it oh yeah
so
um that's the sad part but it's all you
know you know in the beginning it's
lonely it really is because when you're
living with somebody for 10 years wow
and then all the life is sucked out of
the house she took the dogs too oh
yeah so like the first couple of months
it was like you'd wake up it was silent
um you know what I mean it was just
silent in my house it it was like I
don't know how I made it through it man
I was really sad about it but then like
and then I started bringing girls over
and then eating the vagans man oh wow
down there huh hello I'll take the specs
off for them
yeah hey let me start hooking up right
because I you know I haven't done that
for a long time but that's kind of sad
though isn't it like there's some it
gets kind of sad just some gal comes
over and you you know and you hook up
and then she did she now where these
women are these women sleeping overnight
are these women going home one of them
spent the night it was okay so there's
one girl that I was seeing and like this
is maybe seven months ago and I was like
oh this is I like this girl a lot and
then out of the blue she goes I met
someone younger by no and then I I
looked them optim younger than an Asian
I know it was a baby oh yeah she's
getting a baby
he's eight months old yeah yes no um
this dude it hurt my feelings but this
dude look like
Brandon Lee bro who's Brandon Lee
I don't know man
no he was Bruce Lee's
son Bruce Lee's son the crowd he died oh
yeah he died got shot I remember that
yeah he was the first one to do that you
know I mean oh wow he was handsome
handsome dude this dude was
he looked this her should she goes I met
someone younger I looked him up that's
what he looks like oh man and then you
see photos of them like at pool parties
and he's ripped no yeah so I was like oh
you're more together
then you know you're
body style I wouldn't say I wouldn't use
the term ripped probably
yeah I mean but what else about him no
but no what I'm saying though dude is
and I just just said that I'm fat I
don't think you're fat at all
I think you but I'm the opposite of
ripped
I wouldn't see I would say you're I
wouldn't say ripped I would say you're
ripe conjoined or conjoined
I think we could carve one off of you
that's me it did we get carve a little
yeah yeah I guess away dude can I be
honest with you yeah I haven't seen you
in a while you're getting a little bit
too dude yeah you know what I mean and
you got a weird tan huh I do I love it
and healthy look healthy thank you
anyway so she started she goes I met
someone and it broke my heart and then
I'm like but now
I I met somebody you did
yeah man what what what's up we're at
you met her online in here dude no you
better in the DMS remember when I saw
you in that movie you were just swiping
people were sending you wieners and uh
breasts and everything in that movie
yeah no but I met this girl after that
okay yeah I met this girl I don't want
because it's new but it's like um she's
the first person that I kind of want I'm
like I kind of like I like her you know
aside from the girl that betrayed me
with the Brandon Lee you know what I
mean but um yeah I like this new one you
know she's uh
I I oh man I love wholesome
you do yeah I love church going
when they make sweaters what do you call
that
um when they're knitting
I like it when they have they're like
I've never seen Goodfellas yeah right oh
you can show them that it blows their
mind yeah yeah I've never seen The
Departed yeah yeah yeah yeah or it's
like they only this girl that I'm saying
she only likes um Taylor Swift oh yeah
you know what I mean so then you can
open her mind up to like her good music
too you know yeah yeah yeah I mean like
this is good music right here I mean the
Clash or whatever but I like wholesome
dude she goes to church wow twice every
Sunday really yeah what um
ethnicity like what church ethnicity is
she
what do you mean like what uh
I've never heard church ethnicity you
know uh denomination sorry oh
oh I see
I don't know the one with the cross oh
yeah yeah yeah it has to do with the
cross it has nothing to do with other
things yeah like an alien or whatever
Protestant yeah yeah yeah it's it's one
of those mega churches so it's like one
of those born again you know how they do
the Harvest Crusade yeah in like a huge
Stadium
Jesus
yeah is a future
they have that in Oklahoma or whatever
yeah it is in my skirt yeah that's a
good shirt yeah
I saw a guy the other day a gay guy had
a shirt on and said Jesus uh oh it said
God is my girlfriend on it and I was
like that's insane that's insane that's
sexual dude I know it's a lot yeah
that's a lot dude yeah dude the
Christians it gets real gay with Christ
huh well I think anything the more the
the at the at everything the if you get
too much are these dicks touching no
it's too much love if you get too much
love going there's yeah something gay
has to happen like you listen to the
lyrics like you're the love of my life
all I need is you Jesus it's like you're
you're hitting on it's just weird or
Jesus Las Vegas
Jesus loves you yes I know for the Bible
tells you so that's a classic yeah
that's like free bird before Christians
yeah you know I mean it's a class well
it's hard to say you're not gay if you
love Jesus and you're a man
what because you there's a part of you
that's loving another man right right
there is a gay vibe there well there's
just a it's impossible to be
you have to be at least whatever tithing
10 gay to even
do uh Christianity it appears like right
right right gotcha yeah yeah and that's
also can I just say another thing about
it yeah they talk about like I I was
listening to some lyrics of a Christian
song and they said
um Jesus hold me in your arms forever
Jesus has arms
I mean you think about it yeah like he's
just up there as a human form yeah he's
yoked yeah does he shake your hand when
you go to welcome sir you would think
that because there's probably millions
of planets out there with intelligent
life and they probably don't look like
us
so if Jesus is
well there's a Jesus right there yeah
I'm not saying Jesus on planet Earth yes
when he was on planet Earth he had armed
he wasn't a leper right yeah he was like
a third guy you're talking about in
heaven I don't think Jesus has arms in
heaven
I mean he got them reachers on in my bed
I got I bet he got some warm arms too
you think so yeah Jesus yeah
sometimes you can feel Jesus and you're
like sometimes I feel like Jesus is
around or the the love of you know when
you feel like in love with something or
whatever
um
all right Gentlemen let's talk uh
cookware for a second because we need to
if you've been anything like me
you've been cooking out that dirty
Skillet boy that things
oh okay even when you look at it you
just feel bad for anything it's about to
cook that's what I've been using until
hex clad came along
their today's sponsor and they have
revolutionized the cookware industry
that's right hex clad as a hybrid pan
that gives you all the convenience and
cleanup of non-stick the versatility of
your grandmother's cast iron and sheer
durability
and they last a lifetime did I tell you
that that's right they have a lifetime
warranty just in case
something happens if you find a way to
destroy them well while grilling up a
nice grilled cheese for your hinge date
Gordon Ramsay may be the toughest critic
in the world
but these are the pots and pans he uses
both at home and in his Michelin star
restaurants
for a limited time only our listeners
get 10 off their entire order with code
Theo at hexclad.com
support our show and check them out at
hexclad.com and use code Theo I'm
grateful to have some new cookware hey
fellas if you're running into some
stubble trouble up on your grill on your
face
then you might want to tighten up
manscaped can help you they are the
brand for below the waist grooming but
now they're taking care of that face
buddy they want your face to look good
with their brand new handyman electric
face shaver
your face is the first thing people see
you want to keep it tidy
for me being able to save up to three
days growth without the mess of
traditional shaving is really nice
you don't have to get wet you don't have
to get the razor you don't have to do
this and that
just get that handyman out baby and for
my fellas with a little more Scruff
manscapes beard hedger Pro kit has
everything you need to tame your main
get 20 off in free shipping with the
code Theo at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscaped.com and
use code Theo hit the refresh button
with the handyman
Bobby Lee man good to see you dude
yeah
uh speaking of ladies I sent a DM to El
Chapo's wife dude when she just got out
of jail
bring her up please Zachary really yeah
I sent a DM to her just saying what's up
there she is right there
I think you can do better then
you think that you think so yeah I did
then Emma Coronel yeah
plus there's like
your life wouldn't I think your life
would be in danger
yeah but you know your life your life
would be in danger yeah dude but it
would be exciting imagine waking up
every day
and you don't know what's going to
happen my friend yeah and also like
you're sober guy yeah but I could handle
it I would just should be around without
Coke no no maybe I don't know she could
do the coke I'll watch in the back yeah
but she's kind of cute there yeah I'll
just knit in the back or something you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's
pretty cute you've never did I've never
seen you with a Mexican
mm-hmm I would do it man I think
you don't I I think a lot of I don't get
hit on by a lot of Mexicans but I did I
dm'd uh I dm'd El teppas that her she
just got a prison my friend was showing
me a picture of her he's like she's cute
I was like I'm a slide man so
I wasn't gonna bring this up but we'll
see what happens
you ever deemed a
I have a resentment towards you I just
realized
yeah yeah yes sir what is it about you
think
and this is not a lie I swear to God I
swear to God on my life
okay so you know it's real right I don't
know but yeah I'm listening what do you
mean
yeah okay okay whatever yeah three times
okay
on hinge when I was on it and two times
on Raya I matched with a girl
and in the direct message they said yo I
don't want to hurt your feelings but
um I'm not really I didn't match with
you because I wanted a hook I I want to
hook up with Theo can you set me up damn
and brawl
you didn't set me up
how hard would that have been I made
that birthday video for you
bro dude
oh never looked at it that way yeah
how hard you think so I wrote it a bit
when you know your boys out here yeah
looking for love
oh my bad okay look at the Lord's
lost and found out here lost you know
what so you just taught me like I was
selfish about it huh yeah yeah so I
could have been like yo I know you were
you're so hot and I was excited when you
matched with me yeah because I thought
you liked you know I mean the way I
looked yeah and my comedy but you know
you think I'm disgusting but yeah here's
my boy's number because I just talked to
him and he wants to link up you think
that should have happened I think it
would have been the move I think because
here's what I'm saying they say if you
give it you give it away you know
you give it away the more people you
give it away to the more it comes you
know what dude maybe you're right you
know I looked at it in a selfish way
then but you have to admit to it that
that hurts your feeling you would that
hurt your feelings
I think it probably at some point in my
life it would have now I don't think it
would have I've had I've had buddies
steal a girl that I liked and I I think
it yeah made me mad but then I think
like well if they're together then I'm
not supposed to be with that girl oh
dude you know you're looking in a
spiritual way to like everything happens
for a reason I think you are dude I also
put naira in a girl's shampoo one time
who broke up with me when I was in
college so
yeah I get it I get it so yeah I mean so
I guess those ladies because I've been
I've been scolding them online you know
on podcasts yeah hey lady if you whoever
you are you you and all that
stuff damn really yeah I do I get
resentful dude you have a lot of
resentment towards women do you think
honestly or no
here's what I'm resentful about dude
girls I use I hit they're girls that
back in the day like I'm talking about
20 years ago I hit on it's like no but
now they want to link up yeah you know
what I mean now they want to now they
want to link up now now that you're the
top dumpling they want to get in
the sauce huh yeah I'm one of the top I
mean in terms of dumplings dude yeah I'm
in the bowl yeah yeah I mean I mean I
made it into the bowl dude there's like
eight dumplings in there you know now
that you're the b now that you're the
boss Bond me they wanna yeah they wanna
get up yeah yeah but it's like now
they're like you know wanting to but
it's like you yeah you know what I
mean but it's like well I have yeah you
know what dude and what's great about
being how old are you me I'm 43.
you're created I'm 52 now dude you just
turned 52. yeah thanks man I'll take
that bug without a saw a bug
that's not from your apartment is that
some of the things that you have in
there is it no you don't leave those in
here man we just got out of the place I
didn't bring that I'm gonna say hey you
just told me your place gotta shut up I
didn't bring it okay well I don't bring
bugs around bro that's cray cray
one of your stories was at your places I
know but it's not like they're like you
know being like hey let me hitch a ride
well I just one just flew off of you
dude that's the only reason I'm asking
man yeah anyway you seem like a great
guy go on I just want to let you know at
52 though
like that sucks dude
it's just not that important anymore
yeah do you understand what I'm saying
oh yeah man I've like he used to be
number one dude but were you ever were
you ever honestly
were you ever were you ever any good at
sex honestly like were you ever bro
that's so insulting dude no but honestly
I'm great okay then maybe I'm gonna say
something dude
I have two forums yeah slow form and
long form
okay do you understand what I mean by
that man
all right let me think slow form and
long form yeah yeah okay
so sometimes I go short
I mean I go quick oh yeah so that
involves rabbit sewing machine style
yeah yeah
right yeah and then I do long strokes
[Music]
you know oh yeah and that I could do an
hour on that yeah it's like a manatee
swimming oh like a small Manatee
like a manatee
whatever I'm not whatever dude bro who
wants a big big huge wiener that's all
cumbersome yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
you have to have a buddy hold it while
you tie your shoes yeah I don't want all
like I don't like checking in my bags at
the airport dude I bring it on you know
that's what I do but it's at those forms
and then it's like um but that's back in
the day do you enjoy it though do you
enjoy sex as much as you used to you
think
no but I could take I I can go without
it yeah you know like when I was in my
20s I would like stay up all night
hitting on a girl like you know you see
a girl at a bar what do you mean hitting
on a girl you mean masturbating at home
or what do you really mean because I was
I'd be at the house yeah no I mean what
you know like if you were out like when
you're in your early days of stand-up
right oh yeah in the early days you met
a girl on the road and you they were
like on the fans I would like stay hang
out with them till four in the morning
but now it's like I would never do that
yeah like if I was like if a girl walked
in right now
and this is the truth she goes hey so
next door I'm at a hotel when you come
over you know let's and I'd be like
how far is it yeah next door I go I
would go
let's do it right here wow bring me
right here like in front of you like
let's save them up I'm not moving for it
right would you move for it uh let me
think to Next Door yeah I'd probably pop
over there you know all right maybe that
was a extreme example right but you're
saying like like uh Encino you're not
going far out of here yeah yeah I'm not
gonna go to NC now yeah I'm not gonna
yeah you're not gonna get on a map or
something yeah and then it's like also
it doesn't I've never said this out loud
before but I'm saying it man
I can't look at me man
I can't
I can't come really
it takes a long time wow
yeah I'm doing my brother again dude
Bob's doing pretty good that's really
pretty good man yeah you can't come
yeah yeah so like you know but that's
fine you come easy
me yeah well that's one of my problems
with sex over the years has been the um
immediate ejaculation you know it's
almost like somebody not like say
somebody knocked on your door okay okay
no I all right I knock on the door yeah
you open it and I just throw a bucket of
water oh
whoa whoa that's crazy that's too bad
that's too fast it's really you want to
be able to know like the person yeah and
see what they want but you're saying I
open the door it's like this if you even
open the little people thing oh I see I
say that's awesome yeah just yeah what
do you think that is I just a lot of
nerd just like a lot of like I think I
just what I had a lot of nervous energy
around women I was always so scared of
women you know you know dude it's so
funny I've always been scared of cops
and women yeah and it's like you do back
in the day before I did stand up I
couldn't even lock eyes with women dude
same like if let's say you're a woman
and I met you yeah I'd be like hey how's
it going yeah
oh I would even make love and be looking
over there
what wait like a like a spot a specific
spot just like in the you know I just
it's like to be it's so hard to connect
to what I'm doing right if it's if it's
involved I'm making love and this is her
head yeah you're looking over here yeah
I see I think yeah it would just be like
I don't know I don't know it always made
me so nervous like even getting in a
conversation with a woman I can feel my
skin crawl off of my body and into my
butt it felt like yeah like I would be
so nervous so nervous yeah I just could
not even will you be grateful to oh
there's some gratitude in there oh like
thank you God but I would ruin it I
remember one time this girl gave me her
number and I didn't know what to do and
so I ran and tried to jump over this
fence and
cut my body open on the barbed wire what
do you mean at a party really yeah she
was cute and uh and you you started
hurtling toward a fence she like I I I I
I I got her number and she gave it to me
right I don't know if she was out of her
mind or something yeah she's been hit by
lightning or something but she gave me
all seven digits
and I didn't know what to do bro I
couldn't believe it yeah yeah and I
literally turned this way yeah and
beelined we're at this in a at a party
in someone's yard they had a chain link
fence and I was like I can do this I
think part of me is like I'm gonna
impress this girl oh I see and I just
tried to jump over and I got my stomach
hung up on it and got my hand hung up on
it I had to go get a bunch of stitches
it's sweet that's I mean because when I
played that scenario in my head it's
like that it's like yo can I get your
number sure here it is thanks yeah it's
so weird and she's like what the
is he doing yeah right that's your
style that was what you did I just
couldn't handle it yeah I get what
you're saying I was always afraid to
approach I think he just had a lot just
a lot of nervous energy around women so
then I think even in my 20s I would be
like
um instead of going on dates I would do
masturbation you know and because I
would even sometimes I would plan a date
but then I would look at pornography do
masturbation and then cancel the date
it's funny I get what you're saying
because sometimes when I'm like
um I'm gonna meet you know Cynthia but I
don't want to go
like I met this girl Cynthia and I'm
gonna meet our part she wants to go to
this bar when I you're gone then I
called Cynthia and go yeah I'm tired
yeah it's okay I like that I like that
style I'm tired I have to help my friend
move she's like it's eight o'clock on a
Tuesday night yeah let me ask you
something when you're making love to a
girl and you're like doing your you're
looking around like you do and you look
out the window and you saw her in the
window what would you do
if I saw her in the window
I was scared would you be but she was
like like this like her face is right
and then you look down and there's
nothing there oh that would be so crazy
that'd be cool but you wouldn't you'd
want to see her again because she's a
magician yeah she's got talent
right if that was on America's Got
Talent dude
Golden Buzzer yeah
buzzer
how amazing is that dude we need more
Golden Buzzer out in the world
there's not enough Golden Buzzer
man but before explain to your fans what
Golden Buzzer is Golden Buzzer is well
also a golden buzzer is a term I think
in the gay community where someone's
never
um made love to a woman
you know what I'm talking about
or golden whiz or what is it called
a horned Wizard or whatever it's a um
I don't know I've never heard anything
like that before Mom gold star gay sorry
and I think yeah and you also get free
chili I think over there at um no what I
was saying is I like potting with you
because when I pawn with you it's we it
it gets it's like every time there's
some cool weird but I was thinking
to myself are you like that with other
guests you know I mean because I like it
oh really yeah yeah yeah I think I don't
know I mean that's the weird thing about
podcasting is is that you don't really
know how it's gonna go you can kind of
have a little bit of a plan sometimes
but I don't think you can really know
how it's gonna be you don't know how
you're going to be feeling you know how
the other person's gonna be feeling you
don't know what's really going to go on
you don't know if people are going to
tell you sometimes about what's really
happening with them or just want to talk
about just you know the weather kind of
yeah because I had uh
Bobby Robert Kennedy Jr yeah I thought
that was hard I saw that because it was
so scared in the beginning me he did
yeah he was frightened yeah yeah but but
then once he was frightened you know I
mean then I got kind of scared because
I'm like oh I don't think I know what
I'm doing you know I mean but sometimes
you're parting with people and you go I
don't think I know what how to do it oh
yeah yeah it's so weird well yeah I
think you just don't know I mean I think
for one you have to you don't know why
people listen and you don't okay that's
okay let me say something I'm glad you
said that I literally don't know why
they listen
sometimes you know people go you changed
my life or you know what I mean I'm
connect I go I talk about farts yeah you
know what I mean like how did I you know
so that's the first thing and second
thing is is that we do it so much I mean
we iPod so much it's there are times
where it's like what else can I say yeah
but we keep doing it
but today we talked about things I've
never talked about it's a miraculous
really oh yeah I've learned things I
don't know what gold star reviews are I
don't know you know there's just a lot
of things things about you staring off
in the distance when you're making love
that's a new piece of information so I'm
learning a lot yeah from you you know
what I mean but what I'm saying is is
that it's such a
strange
job yeah because it's sometimes it's
hard man you know well I think it's hard
yeah I think there's times where it's
like
I don't know what the like there's times
where it's tough to drop into a
conversation sometimes yeah yeah they
start and go a crazy way and you don't
know what's going on yeah yeah um let me
see what these gold star gays are I want
to be I want to be for sure on this in
LGBT slang oh they got rid of Q
LGBT what's the Q is for queering I
think oh they got rid of it wow wow in
lgdp clang you think the queers are mad
a gold star lesbian yeah they're mad
dude you ever met him
so I'm sure they're not
in LG in uh in their slang a gold star
lesbian is a lesbian who's never had sex
with a man whoa and a gold star gay is a
gay man who has never had sex with a
woman wow so I'm a gold star
heterosexual
no I've I've ever text with a man well
what's sex
I think is putting your body inside of
their body never did not okay I've
tasted some things have you really
get a little bit of that
wait a minute that front soy huh a
little bit you ever you've ever had the
toy yeah a teaspoon of some fellas show
you huh yeah you never have Francois no
no boy you had a little bit off of a
fella
where were y'all
at a rave wow yeah back in the day you
know instead of glow sticks we you know
there are other things going on no you
know honestly you've never had a gay
experience I've never had a gay
experience man now how close have you
gotten this is I'll tell you how close I
was on a porch one time and this girl
told my buddy she told him she said hey
if you kiss my friend and she had a gay
friend there with her gay male she goes
if you kiss my friend then I'll hook up
with you and the dude my buddy was like
all right so he kissed the dude and then
the girl didn't hook up with him oh so
oh no she didn't how mad were you I I
just I was like man I feel bad for that
guy you know kind of but also I think
that guy's a little bit gay you know so
I think it's like a mixed bag yeah yeah
that's the closest you've gotten yep
close I've had let me think if I've ever
seen anything else that seemed uh
there was a gay dude I think or seemed
pretty gay who passed out on our front
porch one time when I lived in
Charleston but we didn't we just saw him
there we didn't do anything to him
that's just that's just a guy who passed
away but still you're asking how close
have I ever that's the closest you've
got you've then you're not close at all
oh a fella came on my own one time at
the movie theater well that's that's
pretty close okay did you know him I did
know him he passed away too
uh
really yeah he passed away passed away
oh that's my bad in a car I mean but I
mean I'm sorry I mean it wasn't your
fault unless you were on the road dude
you guys I have a pension yeah I've
actually like kissed a penis like
intentionally wow yeah because I did you
know what flavor is it first of all you
like I know what vags tastes like yeah
right to me like yeah the quality of
what they taste like is kind of dropped
off a little it has I I it has yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah a lot of these women
it's like yeah you know clean out your
purse yeah it's past the expiration date
too yeah yeah yeah you should put a date
on there yeah if you have a handbag make
sure that you know like it's just it's
not just like yeah but it's a different
flavor badge than dick
so for me it's like I want to see with
the flavor and guess what what don't
like it don't like the flavor dude but
how are you gonna know if you don't
haven't ever had it you guys will eat
anything though dude Asians
I mean you've seen I've seen some
mukbangs pretty intense I mean because
I've been to a China like Chinese market
before Oh yeah and you look at some of
the that like butterfly wings what
the you eat that right or it says
like a shoulder of a meerkat yeah like
you eat that like they like like
sloth toenails oh dude they'll
mix that in they'll have a jar of human
freckles there
that you can you can sprinkle you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
why why are why are Asian people capable
of eating anything why is that
okay I was trying to explain it to you
because it's really true man it was not
that it's not true because let me say
something I want to make the opposite
argument right like I don't know if I
think Chinese people is like white
people they eat sometimes squirrel right
right like you know maybe they don't
with squirrel but squirrels are
weird like I bet you've eaten squirrel
yeah I've had squirrel Asian wheat
squirrel you think so I don't know maybe
yeah dude
there are groups of people that eats
things that we're like oh that's weird
but it's a cultural thing I think I
think they have I think their theory is
that if they move we eat oh right yeah
because it's protein yeah right so if
you eat like the shoulder of a meerkat
you're getting protein right it's about
survival it's about survival yeah and
then that's also it's like but you check
this out just check this out they don't
eat certain things like you you can't go
to a Chinese market and get Panda
oh wow think about it or a koala
well it's all you want they won't eat
cute
but your cats are cute meerkats are
pretty cute yeah but I don't know man I
think I think it's because of survival I
think it's a regional thing like all we
can get it by the pie Wing here yeah
butterfly wing yeah or whatever but but
if I win but yeah but you know what dude
yeah I wouldn't be you think I could you
think I could be Asian or not
dude I'm telling you right now
if they had
if they had a surgery yeah you mean
they wouldn't have to do much really
well from the waist down nothing
yeah no I'm kidding I don't know no
Africa's good really remember dude
accidentally grabbed your wiener the
other night remember that yo why'd you
do that I thought it was an accident huh
was not an accident yeah it was you
gripped it then
I didn't mean to
you yeah but you did huh I just went
like this I know you went down and you
grabbed a little it was on stage yeah
yeah maybe that you know so that's
probably the gayest thing I've ever done
that was probably because yeah but um I
can't believe you met up with so if you
get face to face with a wiener then what
do you do does it who makes the first
move
that's interesting question dude
um I stared at it for like a good 45
seconds there's always a showdown yeah
like you know the Western
so I was there
I backed up well I turned around I did
some steps right that we both turned
around wow right and we just stare at
each other
and then you know what I mean I had my
yeah on my mouth I mean whatever
yeah and then I went
that Wayne or maybe that long so yeah
dude also I was
14 years old 13 years old oh wow you
know I mean so it's like at that time I
was like maybe yeah and then I did I was
like no they call it that long
some people call it that
they do in projects long and
prison yeah they call it say hey buddy
you gotta get you a cut of that long
yeah
gustando Mi podcast
are you liking my podcast
that's a little Spanish to English right
there with Babel
that's right Babel is a language
learning app that can have you start
speaking a new language in just three
weeks one in five Americans have learned
a new language on their bucket list if
that's you you can check it off with
Babel
science says our ability to learn new
languages Peaks when we're children but
since you can't go back to being six
years old
babble's your next best option
it's designed for real people for real
conversations all of Apple's tips and
tools for learning a new language are
approachable accessible rooted in real
life situations and delivered with
conversation-based teaching
here's a special limited time deal for
our listeners to get you started right
now
get 55 off your Babel subscription
only at babel.com Theo
that's only for our listeners get 55 off
at
babbel.com
Theo that's babble.com Theo rules and
restrictions May apply with the busy
fall season already in swing
you might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals for jam-packed days
well factor is America's number one
ready to eat meal kit they can help you
fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian approved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door they're
good they're tasty I had wanna
a week or two ago it was
like a chicken bacon
with the mushrooms and it was it was
just great it was like someone had that
who cared about me had cooked it
you'll save time eat well and stay on
track with your healthy lifestyle
factors fresh never frozen meals already
in just two minutes all you have to do
is heat and enjoy
that's it you can level up with Gourmet
plus options prepared to Perfection by
chefs and ready to eat in record time
they also have all types it'll fit your
diet calorie smart protein heavy all
types so whatever you're going for you
can get through Factor meals
this September get factor and enjoy
eating well without the hassle simply
choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor-packed meals
ready and delivered to your door head to
factormeels.com
theo50 and use code theo50 to get 50 off
that's code Theo fifty five zero at
factormeals.com
Theo 5-0 to get 50 off
Bluetooth baby when you gotta get it
when you got to get some action in that
Randall baby you know what I'm talking
about
when you gotta yerp that churner baby
and you got to get it going
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Cialis and Levitra
but in chewable chewable tablets and at
a fraction of the cost I like them
they're chewable get you a little chew
get you a little Chub baby that's it you
can chew your way to chubbing that's it
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part it's all done online that's right
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code Theo at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code Theo to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast
but I feel like you don't do I feel like
you don't do
weird and bad I think you're uh let
me guess your favorite position
missionary my favorite position is
making love to Civil War Music dude okay
really yeah put on some good Civil War
hits
oh I see
your dick is like a musket
yeah yeah it goes off of the war's over
quick yeah
it is a fast yeah yeah yeah it's a short
one I mean the Civil War you'd be the
north right or anything south oh I'd
have to ride with the South man you know
the Civil War if they ran it back who
would win now I don't know oh dude
oh there it is
yeah yeah
yeah
something kind of nice about it yeah
you want to talk about the movie we did
or no yeah we could talk about it man
what was I thinking about
um
we did a movie yeah we did a movie we
talked about a little bit last time yeah
we did yeah it's gonna come out maybe
maybe not
we'll see we'll see well the strike is
going on you see what Drew Barrymore
which he did about her show what she was
gonna do it now she can she's going to
do it and then she uh she got bullied
into not doing it I know that's what's
so crazy like I don't say I don't think
Bully's the right word no I don't think
she's I mean I don't think she should
have done it like how insane is that oh
my guys to writers
I deeply apologize to unions
I deeply apologize
[Music]
I wanted to own a decision so that it
wasn't a PR
icted situation
and I would just take full
responsibility for my actions
[Music]
I know there's just
nothing I can do that will make this
okay for those that is not okay with
this is bigger than me and there are
other wild house what do you think about
it because so the reason that they're
striking is because
um it's like about residuals it's about
the AI where they're using like there's
a lot of issues right there's a lot of
issues and
um I believe I mean I'm supportive
obviously of the strike on both writers
and actors
um with her it's like just that what in
her mind did she think that like even if
like if I so was supportive of
resistance or not it's suicide
like with Bill Maher too it's like
suicide like just don't work it's also
on top of it dude you're a millionaire
you can wait a year like I don't have no
idea what the thought process is
yeah it's crazy dude it's like I
don't know dude but so what so what is
the thought process that they that they
just want to still be able to work but
it's not we all want to work baby right
so then why are they why would they even
be able to work I think the
justification is like like because you
know you can do reality shows right now
right those aren't effective yes pages
is hosting yeah so Spades you could do
game shows so in their minds they're
probably but the problem with that those
kind of shows with Bill Lamar and her
show you need riders for bits right
they're not improvising it right right
so it's like uh and the writers are on
strike yeah
so she's saying I'm gonna go back and do
it and we'll just hire my own writers
that are not or I'll improvise it wow
and at that point you kind of just are
pot you're you have like if you were not
if you were not yeah exactly if you and
I had an orange show on HBO which we
should but if we had our own show on HBO
you and I would have a discussion like
yeah but we just make up anyway so
why can't we do it yeah so I kind of get
that but it's like at the end of the day
you and I would have looked at he said
yeah but this is not gonna look good
optically yeah you know what I mean so
it's like no I don't I don't know it's a
up it's a weird thing now but
also I want to say this
she's feeling
the the pressure of people online and
and the and and that heat and she's
worried that maybe my career is over I
think that's up too yeah you know
what I mean like am I canceled you know
I mean I'm not
I don't back that at all you know I mean
so it's like she apologized
letter apology because you know we have
no room in our society for Redemption
or like you know I'm sorry you know I
mean so she apologized so we're like
we're good just don't do it again yeah
and if Bill Maher apologizes we're good
but that's what's gonna happen there's
gonna be people in Hollywood that I mean
I'll sucker forever
it's up you know what I mean and
Bill Marshall Bill Martin is still going
ahead with his show but his is just
online right now I don't know yeah I
don't know they were talking about it's
Real Time with Bill Maher on HBO that
he's bringing back without writers and
they're just not doing a monologue it's
just gonna be a panel his podcast is on
YouTube Ah interesting yeah yeah I'm now
is that I mean what then what are what
are people's
arguments against it if he was if he's
just interviewing people well then
what's the problem I don't know right
because you and I are doing that now
right yeah but we're not that's a good
question oh I guess because then maybe
it's just still on television it's like
about that platform I just don't see how
this just doesn't ruin
or you know hinder that whole platform
even more yeah this is an interesting
question what if Comics went on strike
and we couldn't do stand up
or podcasting
what would we do
you would like would we cross the ticket
the line I think people would cross in
the first week probably
I know because Wisconsin
because imagine like oh so there's
there'll be a lot of comics too and I
can name them yeah they'd be like no I
don't work anyway oh Theo and Bobby
aren't doing the improv this
weekend book me yeah and they would book
them it would do it that's a good point
yeah yeah I mean there's so many Comics
that are great Comics who right now
can't do clubs because now clubs are
booking people that can draw yeah which
is like a business thing but back in the
day dude stand up used to be this
especially with the improvs we don't
care if you can draw we want quality
acts is that true oh yeah back in the
day the Improv was like that like we
know so-and-so doesn't draw but we think
he's talented so we'd rather have him
than the guy that's gonna sell out but
now it's now it's all corporate
yeah the only book people that can draw
that's why like YouTubers and you
know I mean they have a fan base you
know sometimes I'll I'll play a weekend
somewhere yeah or three o'clock we have
a YouTube tube show and sold out yeah I
get that you know it's a business but
it's like yeah three o'clock Foods he's
gonna come in here and overdose or
something yeah yeah yeah but 30 years
ago they never did that yeah they didn't
care they were like no we we only book
people that are really good comments I
remember when uh YouTubers were coming
in and doing uh comedy clubs and yeah I
think all of us were like a little bit
like well number one we were jealous
because they were selling the places out
I know dude I know and it was just that
was great it was before we were doing
podcasting and stuff and then but we
took advantage of what they were doing
it was funny because I used to go look
at YouTubers and go what I'm my shows
aren't sold out right but JoJo Santana I
don't know yeah is selling out because
he's you know he has a yeah and then
it's like hemroid Wilson or whatever is
or whoever yeah yeah you know but then I
was like well how do they do that oh
online oh let's figure this out and we
figured it out
and we figured it out and now we did
what they're doing
by putting out content yeah and grabbing
an audience that way and we cut out the
middleman which is Hollywood
do you um
did you see those Mexican aliens
what do you mean
you didn't see them I have no idea what
you're talking about Mexico found the
aliens
Oh I thought you were saying Mexicans
were aliens now look at it right here
let me see
[Music]
Evolution posterior
two aliens dude is that real yeah
they're a size nine and a half they're
little dude yeah they're a little dude
they did like an unbox aliens or Chinese
like it's a Marcus Brownlee video
yeah bro first of all why does that one
have asbestos dude I know but they're
little and they're little Asian eyes and
he's doing this okay I'm not saying yeah
it looked like a Chinese dude who was
using a straw
and he got hit by a nuclear attack yes
yeah yeah go back to it whoa dude that's
crazy so that they found it huh yeah
they found two aliens dude and they
presented them
that's insane I love how there's like
dirt around
yeah
wow and one of them had eggs in it too
they said no yeah
dude I mean there we go dude do we have
any more information about it but come
on good that guy looks like
yeah it looked like he was raised
face first in a in a tuna can yeah
what's wrong with him I know yeah wow
dude wow look at the little nostril
that's cute though oh I think yeah I
wish aliens looked like that oh a lot of
chicks I'm sure have already been in
this aliens DMS for sure yeah yeah
did they show the dick I have to know
the Dig uh I mean I bet it's pretty
similar
to what to Chinese people I I don't know
but yeah wow what a cutie and that looks
like a government thing was that like on
like Mexican it was a Mexican government
yeah they had like a government like oh
yeah Zuma I want to see that's the whole
body let me see
no dick look ooh someday it could be a
woman get in closer what do you mean
it's a little pile of something yeah
yeah God they're so cute huh yeah why
have people been putting cigarettes out
on him though that's what I want to know
yeah yeah that's crazy dude look at the
posture too good posture I think
unbelievable yeah yeah and it's just so
like like dude they can't break
dance I'll tell you that right now
imagine them dude
you know what I mean it's more of a mock
around Macarena it's something yeah yeah
that's a Cupid Shuffle maybe yeah yeah
wow I I man that's so interesting it's
so interesting dude who do you think is
most like aliens that's already on earth
based on the looks of this creature
right here based on the looks oh
here we go
you know uh people with progeria really
you know what that is progeria let's
look it up
you don't know what Progeria is that
disease
I'm gonna get in trouble for saying this
no you're not yeah watch when you see it
you're gonna be like oh
that guy huh
is that that guy has Progeria what is
progeria can you can you bring it up
it's it's they they age super quick oh
yeah I mean it's like the reverse
Benjamin but no it's like Benjamin yeah
reverse Benjamin Button maybe Pro Jerry
also known as Hutchins Hutchinson yeah
dude I've never seen a black one before
let me see the black one extremely rare
Progressive genetics I've never seen a
black person with the Progeria before
let me see
look at this white guy in blackface
trying to do it go down there right
there left that's not what right there
that's a black guy you're right yeah
yeah it's not like well I thought the
attire made me think that it was a white
guy
I thought you were saying a white guy
with progeria was doing blackface
you know I thought it was a white guy
doing black doing uh fake Progeria oh
okay okay I see yeah well what uh
like what a condition huh I can't so so
go back to what the condition is can I
look at it it causes children to age
rapidly starting in their first two
years of life children with progeria
generally appear healthy at Birth wow so
it's a surprise
if we're gonna go down this Lane do you
know what Harlequin ichiosis is uh-uh
don't even Google that then
Harley Quinn yeah yeah uh it's people
that um you sure are you talking about
it's not a movie character is it Joker's
girlfriend no
Harlequin ichio says people born with
like a lyric scan or something oh was it
look it up yeah that's yeah that's what
the baby looked like
so sad like a um it almost has a don't
there's no don't do a joke I'm not doing
a joke they have a um almost a Aztec
look
you know what I'm saying like a
if you saw like art or it almost looks
like a wallpaper like a cave wall
painting yeah is that what you're saying
anything yeah that's not bad
yeah isn't that sad
mom says toddler is happy smiley despite
painful skin conditions yeah but then
they grow up to be they look they you
could they can survive this condition oh
wow yeah so you know
that's cool that's amazing did you um
are there a lot of fears uh in your
culture of a lot of birth fears or there
are a lot of birth years that don't
happen in other cultures
like is there like a lot of like
you know do Chinese people do they have
like can I ask you something yeah
and I honestly believe this I believe
that you don't know what I am
because several times in this podcast
you've refer to China
and then you look at me do you think I'm
Chinese
I don't know if you are no
be honest I don't care if you are I I I
don't I don't I know you I know you
don't I know you know I know that you
don't care that I am okay yeah I know
that you don't care right I mean I do
care but it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter to you you're welcome around me I
know you love me regardless yeah right
but it is information that you should
memorize okay we'll chill bro
it's information you should
memorize because I've known you for 20
or whatever dude
right it's about memorize that dude
because every time I see you
dude it's like China China you people in
China why do you guys eat this you know
how come you guys run this way how come
you fly you don't know how to fly or
whatever whatever you're saying
is I'll I'll be happy to answer
those questions but memorize what the
I am
my bad dude
I'm Chinese all right
I knew it dude dude why do you
do that I'm Korean are you really I'm
Korean dude I'm Korean dude so
it's like God well just admit it get it
off your chest it's not a secret it
Google it it's not a secret what I'm
saying is that every ever since I've
known you you think I'm some other
Asian like when I came in here
would you say
yeah you did dude
or something I'm not from Mom I walk
into you that's the first thing you
say dude damn brother it's
insane dude memorize that dude
you're right let me ask you some
questions and you tell me what they are
okay Margaret Cho Margaret Cho let me
see cho cho cho cho
I'm gonna say uh
uh well
I'm gonna say Chinese no
no no no
let's forget it try one more let's try
one more oh you wanna try another one
yeah
um here's a there's a complex one uh
Steve Byrne
[Music]
I would say cherish
chyrus yeah that's what you just said
chirish Chinese and Irish yes no dude
really yeah Korean too yeah
Koreans will surprise you then we gotta
write this down huh yeah he's kyrish we
gotta get these cairos not Chira we
gotta write this down Zach you're the
right right no honestly Theo bro let me
let's be real dude yeah I love you dude
I love you too brother dude right what
I'm saying dude yeah it's not something
you need to write down it's something
that you could put in your brain you
know how you like memorize different
kinds of corn yeah right and like
different kinds of like condition like
white people conditions you know what I
mean
yeah asthma whatever
you can memorize
what people's at you know ethnicity is
and their nationality and stuff Korean
exactly dude it's not hard do Koreans do
well around like what is the
who is y'all's arch nemesis in the
in the like in the Asian realm do you
guys have like a dude when you seeing
realm it's like you're talking about
Lord of the Rings
or some
is that a realm it's just a part of the
world you know I mean realm okay yeah no
it's not okay oh sorry I'm just thinking
I'm just saying you're like you they
were like warlocks or some
realm dude I'm just saying like what
Wizards don't you with no it's like
no we're just a part of the planet
how about this yeah don't say realm
again okay all right it's crazy but if
y'all were in a zoo let's say that don't
say that
all right all right I could go with that
yeah whatever are you with the zoo too
yeah why people are in the zoo too
the aliens have created a zoo yeah and
there's a white people like a human
there's two aliens in Mexico right okay
they created a zoo I think they can mix
you know what I mean different races in
a in a environment what you're saying to
me is is that aliens would go to the
human zoo and go let's go to the Chinese
section yeah
look at Epcot Center what do you think
that is oh you're right all right so
what they yeah you know what dude they
would probably have an Asian section
yeah and separate them so they would
probably put like um the Vietnamese and
cambodians and the Filipinos in one
section yeah that's fair yeah they would
put but I think they would put the
Chinese in its own section that's a lot
and they put crayons and Japanese
aftermarket too A lot of it what do you
mean a lot of that's after market isn't
it what it was aftermarket Chinese they
make a lot of aftermarket products you
know what I'm talking about yeah yeah
yeah like if you want a replica of like
a
um rear view mirror or something like
that what would that have anything to do
with them being in a room I'm
just saying that's you put them maybe in
a special section go on I'm just at the
afterpart market I'm thinking outside oh
yeah I think oh you're thinking too much
I am I think the Koreans and the
Japanese would have to be separated but
I don't know because time has passed
the other said the Japanese back in the
day did some up yeah they
invaded China they invaded a Korea they
invited to the Philippines you know what
I mean but they've chilled over the
years now they're into like Hello Kitty
and you know what I mean and like
relaxing relax yeah they're relaxing
they like to relax dude they don't have
a military anymore
wow Japan doesn't no
they don't have a military I think the
only kind of gun you can get in Japan is
a shotgun and then you have to get a
punch you have to do a bunch of classes
and you know to get one but my
point is is that they've chilled over
the years that's what the two bombs did
and you know shout out to Oppenheimer
damn so are you Pro Oppenheimer I'm not
pro-openheimer that was a up but
I'm just saying that you know yeah I
mean I'm sorry it happened yeah right so
oh it feels horrible it does it's
horrible there's a lot of pain in the
world
you tell me dude so much pain in the
world though there's a lot of pain in
the world is there pain in your life
um
I'm trying to think what's been going on
I think the toughest thing for me
probably just been thinking about
getting married and stuff like that is
there anyone
is there anyone right now that you want
to marry no
you know I kind of been dating somebody
there's nothing I don't think but I
think it's just a general fear of
getting married do you have that you
think I think when it comes to you dude
and and I I don't you know at the end of
the day yeah you and I are very similar
yeah and I think we have commitment
issues yeah
I think you and I have exterior
struggles that we relate to
um I don't know how you are with porn
but is that an addiction for you I don't
know I've watched a decent amount of it
yeah yeah you know I've seen a lot you
could be a Critic for a newspaper yeah
there was a porn critic you could be one
yeah that's how much you've watched it
don't you think I've seen enough yeah I
don't need to see anymore yeah you could
write articles yeah I could read yeah
yeah
um I think it's bad for you but I don't
think I need to see any more I've used
that for a little bit yeah I just I
watch it a little too much but yeah but
my point is is that and here's another
thing too it's like I know
women like you
I hear it
and yet here you are
alone almost
I know what that is dude are you still
in therapy
yeah Tuesdays every other week at three
yeah yeah
so I don't know but because you know
I've I've known some of the girls I know
you're not a vocal about it I would
never but I've seen you in situations
like with people yeah and some of these
girls that you've seen I've liked really
oh yeah like I I there was one in
particular years ago where I went I hope
that happens yeah I think I remember
that one yeah I hope that happens but it
never happened
never happened so I think that you and I
are um I think it just seems so scary
have you been married
no I'm not you no
of course I'm not you know that you're
gonna die man you're gonna die too dude
yeah well you got to get married I got
no dude I got somebody maybe I will
maybe I will dude
would you propose where would you
propose at
oh I've never you know you know
what I would do dude I would have Shin
limb to you know do something shindling
the magician yeah yeah bring him up
Shin lamb I love things like that yeah a
lot of Asian stuff you can just make two
sounds and then suddenly or you can be a
magician yeah yeah I want Shin to
because I love Shin Lim a lot he's so
talented that guy oh unbelievable dude
so when I propose I'm gonna have Shin
figure out how to do it you know what I
mean but I wanted to be a surprise and I
want some magic involved in it you know
and think about how easy he thought his
name up Shin right and it's in a limb
Shin Lim
yeah but limb is anyway spelled
differently without the B
like see the smoke stuff I would like to
do that but out of my dick or something
oh you're like a yeah yeah I want to
vape out of my dig and then like and
then the ring forms right writes your
name and I go stick your finger in the
Smoke Ring she sticks it in and then
vroom there and I go will you marry me
yeah I imagine smoke coming out of my
dick that's how I'm gonna ask him about
it oh I love it that could happen yeah
how would you propose
I think I would probably get
[Music]
um
probably something old school not on a
cliff I'm not doing anything on a cliff
will it
be a cliff I've never even heard of that
just people always do proposals and then
a lot of times they it's like they fall
yeah there's an X yeah I don't like that
at all so that's too risky I would do
something more ground like more sea
level
I would do
I don't know you don't want to do
something like where you hide it in a
soup or something I feel like that's
kind of ridiculous dude I've never heard
that before really like an alpha like an
alphabet soup yeah but all the letters
just spell like marry me or something
dude that'd be dope dude
have Shin work on it and then after it
says marry me it floats to the surface
of the Ring what do you think dude
that's never happened before did you see
though that one guy went underwater and
wrote marry me on a piece of paper and
he drowned trying to propose to his wife
you see that no let's see that there's
no way that's a thing oh it's 100 it's
so sad
God man don't cry I'm not it just makes
me sad Louisiana man drowns after
underwater marriage proposal
you never got to hear my answer his
girlfriend said no really yeah that's a
real thing a Louisiana and Louisiana man
reportedly drowned after he asked his
girlfriend to marry him in an underwater
proposal she said in a social media post
that's they have the drowning on camera
uh I guess some of it yeah but I guess
part of it they didn't you never emerged
from the depths so you never got to hear
my answer yes yes a million times yes
his girlfriend Kenisha and 12. of course
she's gonna say yes
yes
no yeah even if you were gonna say no
oh we wrote it on loose leaf too and
zero and put it like in a
Stephen Weber or Weber oh dude a second
might as well just do it in an active
volcano like why would that's the
dumbest idea in the world you think yeah
dude underwater
yeah I guess why there's so many places
on like Earth like on land that you
could be original with why would you do
it in a place you could die well because
then that adds an element of risk to it
it's like I'm gonna take a risk for this
look
and you know what I think there is
something to be said for that you know
and he was in an underwater bedroom
apparently there's a bedroom that's
under water and you get to and you can
oh so he went outside of it
wrote it down and proposed and I guess
he couldn't hold his breath for very
long
oh my God so sad I can't even look at it
he never emerged
in Tanzania oh how much time have we
done I don't know about an hour
we'll do a little bit more while you do
more than an hour yeah a little more man
if I'm hanging out with a buddy you know
because I don't get to talk to you that
much
I'll see you next week you're not coming
over tomorrow it's next week I'm gonna
come to the meeting tomorrow Wednesday
morning yeah please come Wednesday
mornings at noon it's at noon yeah
please come I will that's awesome
um is that going well for you though or
no the program yeah yeah you didn't go
out I mean how much time do you have now
16 months maybe wow that's incredible
dude because I'll have two years in
January will you yeah dude January 25th
off two years did you ever almost
relapse or no
I thought about it ever thought about it
yeah I thought about it last weekend
yeah I've thought about it I'm so
stressed I just thought about just
getting me an ice cold beer yeah yeah
it's not just beer it's like sometimes
I'll be like people you know what the
thing is when people are on shrooms
that makes you want to do it yeah like
because I haven't had shroom since I was
17 years old like every time I relapse I
never had it really which I should have
done it then yeah you know I mean but
I've never had it so people are on
shrooms now or you know they go
do the Michael Jason dude yeah you're
like oh I don't know what that feels
like or like some of these other means
things like ketamine yeah ketamine
therapy boy yeah ketamine or um some of
these things but it's like but it's it's
a brief thought and then I can just move
on yeah you know what I mean but um
sometimes when you're on the road
bro
and you're like at a bar
sometimes it's hard then but you know
what I got a bar on the road really you
never I don't go to a bar really you got
something like a couple of times I've
like I've had girls go and you know me
and my friends are here we're at
Charlotte's place or whatever and I'll
go over there you will I'll go if
they're super hot yeah right and I'm at
Charlotte's place and I try to act cool
and stuff but it's like it's not good
and then like they're drinking and
sometimes I'm like but then I thought to
myself if I did drink I would probably
do that I will regret the next day
right
like you know hook up with somebody that
yeah because you know I'll be honest
with you you and I are tastes have been
sophisticated or sophisticated really
you're not I don't know I think it is
what do you mean when you say that what
I mean is like you know I I like to date
women that are not just only attractive
but there are
that you know I mean are bright and cool
and have all the you know I have a
checklist of things you know I mean a
couple of I've had some suspect ones
have you oh my God yeah I mean I can't
talk about it but I have have you met a
girl off of the DMS and just went to
meta meet her at night in the middle of
the night
I did that a couple times wow was that
scary I mean I did some stuff I can't
even talk about on this podcast that
were like wow like I should be more
careful really like crazies really yeah
Lady of the nights you know I mean wild
eye wow yeah and is this have you been
to any like sex dungeons or anything
like that
like any ever been anything no I've
never been in a dungeon man a Sex
Dungeon that's not my thing yeah have
you done that no I don't like dominatrix
you know it's so funny my I'm just as a
human being I'm a very simple guy dude
really I like a nice meal
you know what I mean do you eat the same
thing every day
it's funny if you look at my Postmates
and my doordash there are six places
that I just rotate like what are yours I
like Mediterranean food about once a
month so I go to Mediterranean so I go
Panini Cafe ever been to Panini so I get
kebabs there oh yeah yeah okay so I'll
get like chicken or steak kebabs I'll
get like a salad and then you know it
comes with the balsamic rice whatever
but I also get like cucumbers and hummus
like so I do that so I with that
another thing that I go to is I'll do
one Smash Burger Place yeah yeah I go to
High hop like fatty Burger yeah like
fatty Burger they always some of the
names are kind of offensive it's like
Hey fat burger like and you're
like yeah yeah like fat sales that's a
place yes Fat Burger yeah yeah don't put
fat in the thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're right yeah I don't go to
those places that often because of that
work yeah another place that I go to is
um
like that that and then I'll do dude I
do sushi once a month at a place have
you ever been to awesome
in Studio City is it good it's the best
really yeah I gotta take you there and
then um dude I with hot dogs bro
really no here's a here's another Glizzy
gobbler huh a gobbler you like Lizzies I
love it but here's another
I don't know what you're saying how many
of you had so many Lizzies glizzies I
love the Glizzy pull up a Glizzy dude
what is it it's like a BL it's like a
hot dog at a black guy's house I think
really yeah you haven't heard of
glizzy's dog but you know what I'm
addicted to fast food Arby's dude
oh there you go there's Adam what's his
name Adam 22 eating one
yeah there's a guy using one as a gun
yeah
Glizzy gobbler homie there's a lot
of Democrats eat it huh yeah I guess
dude
that's a Grizzly Glizzy yeah that's a
Glizzy don't you like hot dog you like
hot dogs I like hot dog yeah you like a
dog
would you rather be you think you think
it could be Mexican or not
dude put these glasses on let's be
mixing for a minute dude
okay
oh what I'm watching right now son I'm
watching my teal play um horseshoes oh
bro you know what I like bro what I
like everybody I heard you bro oh you do
you old school old school hey bro look
at me
yeah yeah
also dude you know what I like a dude I
like I like Carlos
you do bro bro I like Senoritas Bros
dude we would be so cool dude we would
be the best
we've been the best oh
I want to say something to you and I
wasn't gonna say this and I'm sorry you
might have to cut this out yeah but I
have a dude
who do I where's my camera right here
yeah
last night
I went to the Ice House
have you been there uh-uh you know what
it is yeah they redid it they redid it
and I wasn't gonna say this
it broke my heart when I was there last
night hmm
I'll tell you how
the Fishers used to own you know Bob
Fisher you remember him great guy great
guy it used to be like The Comedy Store
you know I mean like Legend they didn't
change it when you walked in like oh
yeah this is the ice house from back in
the yesteryear yeah it felt that way and
I walked in there it was like walking
into like Andes Hotel they changed it
yeah not only did they change it so I
park in the alleyway where I usually go
right yeah and I listen I'm not I'm not
I I know I'm not Dave Chappelle right I
know I'm not Chris Rock I know I know
where I am in the comedy scale yeah all
right but also I'm not an open micro
either I've been around I've done some
yeah okay so I park in the alleyway
then I go how do I get in the club I
knock and there was a guy that works
there he's like yo man what you want and
I go uh I'm playing in the main room
doing like two shows you gotta go around
can you just open this only Comics I
opened that for
I go to Bobby Lee yeah go around
so I finally get him to open it and he
goes you better be a comic damn that's
what the guy says so I'll go okay well I
walk around I know where to go so when I
go to another person I go where's the
Green Room he's like why would you need
the green one that's for Comics no yeah
I swear to God you think they was doing
like a prank no that wasn't a prank it
wasn't a prank then
I walk around I see a waiter
that had been there in the old days so
where's the manager are the manager
sitting right in front of you and I look
at him he won't even look at me yeah he
doesn't say listen I haven't been there
since it's changed the it's the
assistant manager and the manager they
don't know who the we are wow and
what I'm sorry dude if you're at a
comedy uh
you think we're getting too old though
Bobby
say something okay I was at Cleveland
maybe they're like they like Bryce hall
or they're like fans of like um
you know I don't know although so
they're only Trevor Trevor Wallace fans
I don't know I'm just trying to maybe oh
we only like Taylor Thomas and Trevor
Noah yeah people that are in their 20s
and 30s I don't think so dude because
when I went to dude I went to three days
ago I went to I was in Cleveland and I
went to a restaurant and it was next to
hilarities and I looked at Jesse Johnson
and I go let's go to hilarities I want
to introduce you when I walked in there
I wasn't planning there that weekend
the owner comes gives me a hug
gives Jessie a hug they give me a tour
they go whatever you want we love you
they're like family to me yeah then
Jesse curaca was performing Jessica
Carson Jessica Kirsten I wanted to go
say hi hugged her right you know I mean
it's family that's what we are dude this
is what it is yeah when I walked in the
ice house dude it was like I went into
like a place I wasn't supposed to be
right and then like Whitney and Natasha
was there too and they I mean I didn't
get deep into it but I feel like they
felt the same way really yeah so my
point is is that change your man
wow it's disrespectful bro wow don't act
like don't act like you don't know I
like I don't belong there yeah I mean I
think it's strange if you go somewhere
and you don't feel like then you won't
want to go back man I'm never gonna go
back wow and I'm sorry you know it's so
funny it's like I have these little
weird things I mean I and maybe I need I
need to go to therapy about it because I
get mad about little like that oh
yeah no I'm being real I get I there's
little things like one time I was
playing Bellevue Parlor Live oh yeah
I've been up there before and that guy
falls asleep sometimes yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he had a condition yeah and
then the second show I did there so I
did a show Thursday Friday night at
first show second try left came back and
they wouldn't let me in the club
and the doorman goes amen we're sold out
and I go
on the headliner like you know what I
mean yeah like I'm just some
lost fisherman right when that
happens I don't know why but I lose my
dude I just I don't know is is that
me is that am I too sensitive I don't
know I know is it ego it could be ego I
don't know but we all have ego ego gets
scary man that's the scary part about
all of it I think uh like your ego can
be so dangerous it's like a um
you know it's a party that grows
sometimes we don't even know what's
going on yeah I've been it's funny when
when I was reacting like that last night
I I I I I tried to like
stay in the moment and go are you
overreacting let's let's be you know I
mean let's see what this is about and
then I realized no it's up yeah I
do spend time and go listen where are
you at how how what what's your part to
play in this well I think places are
just having tough times hiring people
all type like you'll go to a bakery now
and the guy working there like does like
oil changes you know like I think people
don't have like people that know comedy
working at comedy clubs anymore like
people are just hiring whoever they can
you know no but but that's ridiculous
because it's like if you go to the laugh
at your improv they cannot there's not a
single moment in my life yeah where I've
walked in the the Laugh Factory and they
go no you're not allowed in here it's
always like
they don't say anything because they
just know you belong there but that but
they have a history of knowing that
you've been in there I think you know
and I think I've been going to the ice
house since I was in my 20s but I think
that you these people I don't know dude
but I think yeah it's like you got a guy
who's working at a you know you got a
guy who works at Jiffy Lube now working
at the bakery counter yeah
I'm just saying you got a guy it's a
weird analogy yeah yeah yeah yeah what
do you mean like I'm in a background
like April I used to work at jupitloops
I don't know how to make bread is that
what you're saying no I'm just saying
you'll have a guy like hey bro you want
you need two quarts all right
I see what you're saying yeah people who
don't know what's going on yeah give a
butcher working at the barber shop you
know yeah oh I don't need much dude all
I need this is what I need at a common
club right I don't need you don't even
have to be a fan
you know what I mean I don't need people
to go I'm a big bombing in fact there's
a lot of people that don't think I'm
funny at all right I know that I don't
care but just at least treat me like I
Emma comic yeah that I belong yeah to
this place that like you know it's crazy
right well I think that it is you get
people that don't even know about
Communists like I'm a door guy I'm a
balancer whatever I'm a chef but I was
talking about the manager and the
assistant manager didn't know and then
finally the manager comes up to me goes
hey man I heard you were upset I go yeah
I mean I walk in here this 45 minutes
now I meet you yeah he's like what's
your problem and I go well I mean I
haven't been here since you guys changed
I've been coming for three years you
would think that the manager would be
like hey this is what's changed about
right and he goes well I could show you
around now yeah I guess too late yeah
well we want things when we want them
dude I gotta ask you this what about Joe
Biden falling asleep all the time how
weird is it do you think it's weird we
continue to put him out there as like a
like as he's a normal dude it starts to
feel like really mean don't you think
it's a thirst job what you're doing
not at all I'm not gonna buy I'm not
gonna bite the bait
do you think it's a bad thing to talk
about
I just think it's uh here here's the
deal okay
both options
I don't like
but to me one guy is still the lesser of
two evils that's all I'm gonna say
okay
what do you think
I think that it's wrong to put a guy out
there who is not doing well mentally
right now it seems like he needs it just
seems like he's suffering and no matter
who the person is it's a bad look at how
we treat our old people if we put a guy
out there who it seems like has dementia
I could be wrong maybe a lot of videos I
see are edited I think but the other day
he said I'm going to sleep I'm going to
Betty bed right now yeah because he was
tired that's what people I say that too
when I go I'm going to bed yeah yeah
you're right I have to see it yeah
if you don't know what you want
at the meeting
if you don't have a game plan he may
have a game plan he just hasn't shared
it with me but I tell you what I don't
know about you but I'm going to go to
bed
yeah that's what people say that's a
good point yeah
let's talk about what we talked about at
the conference overall we talked about
stability we talked about making sure
that never mind I mean if you go Hey Joe
Biden how's life I'm a Taekwondo
instructor yeah like if he's like
answering questions like that then I'd
be like oh dude so you need another
level I need another level of like of
crazy for me because even when Mitch
McConnell froze later they did a
cognitive thing and and other senators
are like oh he's fine yeah he just
freezes he freezes every once in a while
dude oh dude if I've had a lot of ice
cream I'll get all Mitch
McConnell yeah yeah if Mitch McCullough
was the quarterback for the you know La
Chargers and you freeze during a play
then that's one thing yeah but you can
freeze every once in a while as a
politician you're right dude we're kind
of overreacting I think we're
overreacting
um we got some pictures that we made uh
we made we got some AI pictures of a lot
of comedians put together cool that were
of being children let's check it out
Dave
um yeah we've been playing around with
AI we asked it to show us scenes from
famous comedians from their childhood
okay cool
do I guess who the community oh my God
oh that's so can I can you send me that
we'll see what we can do no can you send
me that I don't know if we have a copy
of it
the other top that's me right that's you
a dead dude this is AI what AI thinks
your childhood was like it makes me
heartwarming I look very handsome pretty
cute God you were cute and look what you
were eating too go back and see what he
was eating wow wow that looks like
shoulder of a meerkat it looks very I'm
not gonna say illegal yeah but uh do I
look Korean or Chinese there
okay let's move on
next one cute okay
that's you yeah that's pretty good dude
you again that's really good
awesome
okay now here we go
oh that's so funny they're just Caleb
and yeah that's awesome yeah that's a
great picture yeah boys
a civil war that's amazing
let's see if I can zoom in
who is that
Shane Gillis again nope see the next one
that's uh David spadeen
oh let's see if it's bad
oh I know that guy it's not Fred Savage
it's not nope do you know who it is
yeah
oh I know can I guess yeah samurai oh
that's a great guess it should be it's
Mark Norman Mark Norman we can't all
any guess
Tom Segura
oh that's um
that's uh Chelsea yeah
that bike is cool huh who's that
dude I don't know who that is huh it's
Hannah Gatsby
isn't it yeah yeah now that's Hannah
Gatsby now who is that Snover of calcius
oh I see that's good that's good that's
good okay I'll buy that that's awesome
next
Tim Dillon yeah it's Timmy D boy
that's it for these and then we also
asked it to show us older what you look
like when you're older okay cool that's
good I can handle it
yeah that's me I took that photo you did
yeah yeah it's sources from like what's
out there on the internet wow I hope
you're okay oh yeah look at you making
the uh sporting equipment yeah and we
asked it to advance to end of life
oh and what are the odds you were just
saying earlier with you not having any
legs yeah yeah oh oh my that's end of
life how'd you lose your legs you think
that I didn't lose them they're inside
my body now oh they are yeah I got the
operation oh that's beautiful yeah
we got old Theo oh damn dude it's
getting bad it's getting bad dude
oh Andy thank you so cute that one looks
exactly like how he's gonna look that's
what he's gonna look like yeah that's
what Andrew's gonna look like oh
oh that there's no way when he's gonna
look like that that isn't Whitney man
that's your ex-wife is that kalila yeah
oh it's hard I believe she moved
out man all right let's move on dude I
want to talk about that anymore
but that looks like Robert De Niro yeah
oh um that's uh jbj yeah yeah he looks
the same looks the same yeah looks great
Gabriel yeah
huh oh Joey
this might be sad though she didn't go
how old would be sad woman yeah there is
something to say about it yeah you know
what's weird is we enter the second half
of our Lives Bobby that's what I'm in
the SEC I'm in the last do I mean the
last chapter right now dude
or whatever yeah it is that's the end do
you start to think I mean is there any
do you feel honestly dude like really do
you feel like it's time for you to have
a family like it's time for you to I
think it is I'm ready I'm not only am I
ready for it but it's like
um I want it
I want it and also because I'm good with
kids dude I mean this girl that I'm
seeing now has a kid really yeah and um
how tall is the kid
pretty tall wow you know and um I'm
really good with him I you know uh we
got our kids and um we talk about
Pokemon and then we also do this stuff
and we play with the stuffed animals in
his room before he goes to bed oh man
and I like all that stuff and I think
that I could be a good dad then
um I'm not good at the disciplinary
stuff I'm not good at like I probably
wouldn't get up in the morning and make
lunch but I'll pick him up from school
and I think that I could have say some
white you know what I mean but um
yeah but I had but you know what the
love would be there yeah I think it
feels the same with you I think would
change our lives dude anything will
change your life yeah I think it would
man I think it I think it would what do
you think's been the scary thing for you
and I mean I'm happy to talk about it
for me too but like what's the scary
thing you think about going there about
good like doing it you know it's stuff I
have to give up
right I Gotta Give Up Starfield
and and stardew Valley and video games
I can't play it as much yeah
um I think that I would have to change
my sleeping schedule
like today I woke up at 1 30. oh yeah I
texted you oh dude you have this
sleeping schedule of a wombat I feel
like yeah yeah I do yeah so I have to
change that and I think I would change
my language really yeah I'm filthy yeah
yeah I mean um like yesterday I I also
Behavior So Yesterday me and uh Jesse
were you know how sometimes you have to
take a
um from the rental center for the car to
the airport you have to take a tram you
know what I mean yeah so we were one of
those shuttles yeah it was packed
completely quiet and literally I'm
standing me and her are the only
standing and I go watch this and I've
been over and I ripped a fart
that was so loud yeah and it made it so
uncomfortable and me and Jesse were
laughing but everyone was pissed they
were pissed yeah yeah I mean there was
one dad that was like dying laughing
yeah because it was so loud but it's
like I do that all the time and I have
to change probably that
I dude I always you always I feel like
the thing that that's like the uh you
want to always everybody wants to really
rip one in like a public setting yeah
you know let the gods speak you know
yeah I don't know yeah yeah so it's like
um but do you think you could really do
that and could you live in a house where
when you wake up and your wife is right
there with you in bed and then like then
if you go in the kitchen she's also in
the kitchen
yeah and also
that sounds disturbing to me
she's everywhere right that's the part
to me for some reason that feels
overwhelming right and also number two
I noticed because you know the girl that
I'm seeing now she's showing her best
side
you know what that's what they do yeah
and I'm showing my best side like I
don't do rippers yeah you
know what I mean in front of her what is
that blowing it out your nose or
something no just fart oh yeah yeah yeah
I don't do like you know some of my
nasty yeah I I say you know I um
I I show her the best sides of me yeah
right and um
and then you know what happens is you
you commit to the person and you guys
live together and that's when oh she's
in every room oh now it's a problem that
I'm playing video games too much yeah
yeah all those things that come up so
I'm not really interested in that I'm
not doing that but are you gonna let
them know first this is kind of how I
live my life like that's the scarier
thing as we get older is I hear from my
friend who haven't gotten married to
other orders that it gets harder to get
like like the it gets harder to
match with somebody because you have too
many you know uh but I but when you I've
thrown my boundaries out there already
I've never done this before so I've said
that like you know if I ever get married
we're sleeping on two separate beds yeah
in two separate rooms yeah and they're
like well that's weird I just think that
it's better
if I have to go on the road or you know
me or I'm playing video games all night
I don't want to keep you up right and
you do your own thing so it's like
that's that yeah and if they don't like
that well then it's not going to work
out yeah I mean there's just certain
things that like also but another thing
that I do is you know I'm like but you
know what dude every meal I pay for
whatever you need you'll have wow huh
whatever you need you'll have unlimited
dim sum dim sum and you can do whatever
you want I will support you yeah if you
were like you know what me and my son we
want to go to Canada for like and he's
never seen Vancouver I'd fund it go go
go go I don't give a right but it's
like don't get into my and tell me
when to sleep when to wake up do any of
that dude what do you think I think
yeah I think the scary part is just like
I don't know I never wanted it to
anybody to be at like I never
I don't know I always like kind of being
by myself I always like being able to do
whatever I want to do
uh yeah what about this then but at a
certain point it's pretty lonely yeah
let me ask you this could you do this
could you do
this is your part of the house and this
is my part of the house
and then you know you design your part
the way you want to design it and every
once in a while
because several times in a week we'll
meet in the middle of the house have
meals smash do whatever hold hands or
whatever but for the most part I'm gonna
stay on your side and you stay on your
side would that be good for you
it's like a Red Rover Red Rover kind of
yeah like a Red Rubber yeah yeah yeah
yeah like Red River Red River I'll see
you at dinner yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think I could maybe do something like
that yeah but they would never go for it
you'd have to meet a girl that would
want to do that but I also I have a
problem sometimes of being up like
saying what I need in the beginning so
it's like then things get going and it's
like I don't say what I need you know
and it's like that's that's what I'm
telling you to do it now I've been
trying to do it now like this is my
thing
also here's another thing I say up front
you can never say hey can Sunday nights
be about us and not do stand up no
stand up will end my business and my
career will always be first be first
really
like if it's your birthday yeah or
anniversary yeah yeah if someone dies
and we you your Uncle Jimmy dies and we
have to go to his funeral I'll go yeah I
can smoke there I'll go right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I also want to dress
the way I want to dress yeah yeah I mean
I'm gonna wear my Poncho and my
cowboy hat bro but my point is is that
yeah so there's certain things like that
but it's like no I'm it's literally
what I do and it's who I am yeah
podcasting and stand up and acting like
imagine a girl going yeah you can't do
that movie because it's our anniversary
and you told me you're gonna we're gonna
go to Paris no no I'm doing the movie
yeah I mean so you got to say that up
front do you think you'd be willing to
spawn your own child to hatch your own
prawn as they say
I have proof but I'm not going to tell
you what it is my comment is strong my
friend really so you can do it still
strong as dude wow boy boy it's
good we got that dim yum yeah I got them
yums dude how about your calm I don't
know it's it looks a little risky
sometimes but I haven't really like
gotten in there and you know I haven't
gotten in there with like a
uh like a magnifying glass or anything
yeah you don't do that you can go to the
doctor and do it I think you
don't have to do your own home kit but I
think you just put it under like a um
like a microscope yeah can you see if
your semen works well just at home
you don't think you can I'm sure you can
but I just I just never heard like a
home kit but why drive over to
somebody's place you don't really know
wait maybe the doctor waste a load it is
okay here we go there you go
and what's the rating like how much
what's the max you can get
a chart here but that's on a chart
though is it
a normal range yeah
um that's something I think about dude
but you gotta still have that I have it
still you gotta have some beef in the
batter huh I still got some beef in
there dude yeah how to test sperm count
oh you can do with water even
oh you come in water it's so yeah oh
they're like sea monkeys uh yeah
that's what I feel like the zoo would be
like in uh in in on a different planet
um and Well a different country I feel
like an Asian Zoo would be like welcome
to the zoo can I take your order
yeah and they'd have great food they'd
have the best food
um well the photo down there is that
what sperm looks like yeah let's get
that sperm let's see a real close-up
look a real sperm can you Google that
high res sperm
dude that's high-res right there look at
that whoa dude
whoa dude Papa Got a Brand New Bag huh
whoa dude
that's crazy oh
they look great huh they look pretty
good yeah yeah wow it's very uh and the
ovary looks like the sun it looks like
one of those bosses on uh breath of the
Wild
yeah maybe yeah you know yeah yeah or
when that moon comes up you know what
I'm talking about yeah
those yellow Asian Sprouts that you eat
Korean Korean restaurants oh yeah
um we had a couple news stories was
there anything good and we'll get Bobby
out of here
how long do you go for podcasting yeah
hours I do 50 minutes you do yeah what
is this why do you do it like this I
don't get to hang out with you I
know I'm gonna see you again will you
yeah dude what is this why do you do it
so long it's fun it's
they want it
what do you guys think
you shut the up in your you
should film me I'm Instagram famous you
bum shut the up
wow
I'm not shocked at people I mean planes
are getting weird huh yeah people are
stressed out and people are not used to
being around each other in person
anymore people are starting to get I
think this is what's happening okay
online people can say whatever they want
right so when it gets back and their
people are online more than they're in
real life these days so when it gets
back to being in real life
people feel think they should be able to
say whatever they want to online but
they can't because it's not the same
setup and it makes it it's it creates
this weird uncomfort you know does that
make any sense yeah what she just said
I'm Instagram famous too I think people
are entitled too
like like that thinks she's
entitled to say mouth off like that
right I think yeah people think she's
better than the people that are in the
plane yeah we're all the same
man yeah you know so it's like
um that's why I wish everybody should
have to carry a piece of their own
with them
because then nobody would think they're
better than anybody else
in a bag though not like out like in the
open not thinking the open dude because
then somebody's got a nicer bag than
somebody else somebody's gonna have
their shipment Gucci could make a bag
yeah how about this like no it's not no
how about this is the best way
somebody's gonna have a fandy turd or
whatever we have it's a law okay right
it's like you know um an Altoid box yeah
so it looks like an Altoid box but it's
see-through it's like completely clear
you put your poo in there but it's in
sealed then you wrap it around your neck
and it's like a bling
right but everyone has to have one I
think that would humble people
like some people might have like things
in it like peanuts my mind has peanuts
how about yours yeah but you guys use a
lot of peanut and a lot of sauces and
stuff yeah but yours is just a solid
Brown no I think mine I tend to run a
specific color like during certain
seasons of the year I think oh but
spring is different but I think if you
had to carry it in your hand okay I mean
it's insane yeah that lady seems like
she's nuts on to the next story
yeah
uh Lauren bobert I know about this oh
yeah she's the Colorado rep yeah I know
somebody was yumming on them somebody
was handing on them yummers baby yeah so
this is the actual the surveillance
video Yeah somebody was Hamming on them
porch milkers baby
God huh
do you think she should apologize for
this
oh it's another here's another thing let
me say something okay it's another thing
of entitlement
she said I'm a congresswoman I can Vape
because when I choose Vaped in there too
right I can Vape in there I can mouth
off I mean I'm I'm above everyone else I
can you know behave in a way that's uh
out of pocket you know just because I'm
a congressman but do you think she
should be able to get her breasts felt
in public is that that's not out of line
if her or the man want to consensually
do it in the dark if her kitties are
being rubbed in the theater that's fine
if that wasn't the thing if that was the
only thing that'd be fine but she was
acting a fool too like vaping and
heckling dude yeah wasn't she heckling I
haven't seen heckling I just heard
vaping and groping all right well that's
damn boy she got them bomb tonsils on
her baby you know what I'm talking about
yeah she got them reused would you marry
her I don't know if I would marry her I
don't know her I don't know her either
but I you know yeah I look I'd I'd
probably
I'd go see a flick also watch the movie
Beetlejuice why do you want to play
that's true huh yeah yeah I don't know
if she's my type I don't know
yeah no that's not my thing
but apparently she's got them big
Dippers baby
all right anything else brother in the
news
uh there's just something going on right
now there's a jet that's missing that
just went missing um oh yeah and they're
asking the Public's help for that
a jet an after uh was it F-35 yeah it's
a fighter jet just went missing over
over South Carolina the pilot ejected
safely but I guess um they just found
debris of it yeah well if he ejected
then he's fine he's probably in the
forest the Pilot's fine they can't find
the plane they left it on um
read it let me see it Zach yeah this
just came in um they're starting to find
a little bit of debris in South Carolina
but they haven't found the whole plane
but it was crazy they were asking the
public have you seen our plan
that's crazy dude it's getting to this
weird space where
um
oh did you see that mosque might charge
for Twitter did you see that
yeah
whatever in two years because they stole
my account oh they did yeah some guy's
running my Twitter account for two years
I can't get it back really yeah and then
now he's selling computers
do I haven't been on my Twitter and I've
tried to hire professionals yeah to get
it yeah I'll give you 10 grand yeah
they're like we can't do it you're guys
yeah anyway what do you think about this
uh suggest he will charge because he's
saying this the only way you can get rid
of bots is that what he's saying Elon
Musk may flip the switch to make X The
Social Network for me on his Twitter an
entirely subscription-based platform
wow I mean that way maybe I can get my
account back to the point
because the guy that stole it might I
want to pay for it to your point yeah
that's what he's saying he's saying
nobody's gonna pay for all these Bots
and if and if you have to we can you
scroll up some
must didn't mention the timing of his
plan to charge Twitter users nor did he
say how much it would cost I think
that's a great idea dude because it's
like people can like you know like you
know I know dudes that like comment
like dudes like rip me apart right right
and then like I block them but then
there's a screen another account because
I can tell it's the same guy in terms of
the language and their aggression you
know I mean so maybe that's a good way
to do it dude
because apparently the advertising sales
I guess because he's the CEO people
think he's uh I guess maybe they don't
politically align with them or they just
don't align with them
it says 50 uh that ad sales are plunged
we're still negative cash flow
advertising Revenue maybe Twitter will
go down like Vine
I don't think it can though why I think
you you got to have it stay up if people
can just talk on it
where else would people be able to
communicate the one I'm gonna joined
truth social dog what's up whatever
you're on is it good okay it's Trump's
one oh it is I did I do I do belong to
it but I only do it so I can read the
crazy it's a crazy on there
well I just I just love seeing like
people go like like I just love the
things that people say like that you
know the Q Anon people yeah I like
really reading their crazy ideas there's
some deep stuff in there I don't know
enough about it but what is this go down
a little bit more I just wanted to see
one more thing that he said here
um X's other benefits
one of the chief perks of X blue is
getting verified check mark but
everybody can pay for their check mark
now
I think they're saying if there's less
if if people pay for it that there won't
be as many Bots because he's trying to
get all the bots off of the app
also can I just say about checkpoints
and stuff like that it's like the whole
point of it was because and I'm not I
mean I don't care one way or another but
it's like the reason why you know we I
wanted to check mark is because 40 dudes
were like making accounts with my name
yeah and I want people to know that this
is the real one yeah but now like other
people are like I want to check mark too
because it's like a sign of like
privilege or you know being but it's
like why yeah sometimes like my wife
died in a fire I need a check yeah
you're like you know yeah yeah yeah they
think that anything you know I guess
it's a it's a feeling of like I'm
important
you know I mean like I know a comic that
like never got a check mark because this
wasn't big enough and then like but then
now he pays for it now he feels great
but it's fine anyway dude let's go I
gotta eat yeah this is insane it's like
two hours I didn't know you've been here
two hours
you've been here one hour and 21 minutes
that's not true it is
right under two hours
40. that's fine
um I'm gonna be on yeah go promote
tigerbelly next week right yeah or
tomorrow and let me see next week next
next Tuesday yeah I don't know when
it'll come out though it's fine and then
also uh I want to also say that dude I
mean
I'm just so proud of you're killing it
oh thanks man you guys are too dude
we're doing pretty good I think we're
all good but I watch I look at you and I
go oh my like I remember me and Andrew
the other day were like watching one of
your crowds
like it was pretty crazy yeah and we
were like holy I mean it's like you
can just tell it's a completely
different deal dude thanks but guess
what dude why
you don't intimidate me at all man
really I don't give a dude I'll
hide drugs up your ass but what
I know you remember I honestly I'll hide
drugs up your ass and throw you over the
Border no one remember what happens man
you know what I'm saying but I'll say
this though you've been touring a lot
more thank you man I feel lucky for sure
you've been touring more than you ever
have I know I'm uh how is that why has
that changed for you because you didn't
used to do that
oh this is Andrew making me
but are you enjoying it no
but I'll tell you what no it's no here's
why I like it
I like it because
um
you know honestly if I wasn't touring I
would just be like I'm a loser or
whatever but you know it's nice to go
out because then you realize because in
L.A no one says anything but when you go
out in the world like people are like
I'm a fan and you kind of go oh well
maybe I am reaching an audience and
stuff so it feels good in that way you
know yeah I like meeting people and
hugging them and going and and talking
to them like thank you for listening and
I'll you know and you get to like
because we do meet and greets I don't
know if you guys do those yeah yeah and
it's like it's good to hug people and go
thank you so much for your support and
uh it makes me want to keep going so
it's nice it's cool that way we had a
guy that got hit by a train and I got to
meet him recently yeah he came out yeah
he walked he walked he's walking bro
okay walking
walks across a train track train hits
him had headphones on
listening
got to meet him there he is right there
buddy that's it rail baby they call him
that guy got hit by a train yeah he did
he looks so but I mean he's so small
I don't know more of them before you
guys yeah it just kind of flew off of it
or I don't know I don't know he got
drilled pretty good man he's an American
hero dude yeah yeah and uh but yeah
you'll meet people that are calm people
let you one lady let me hold her tit
with the Sodom arm the other day biggest
hit you've ever seen you see people with
we had one guy lost part of his skull
doing something and uh he he came out he
had a hat on but he took the hat off and
you can see part of it was missing but
then he could go like this
and it would inflate the full
dude no way swear no way dude bro we met
some of the greatest people man yeah
people are doing do a nice cross stitch
for you somebody made me a rat Crown the
other day with different rats yeah and
also you know I'll be honest with you
it's like I
you know like we could we do the South
or whatever and I real I go oh like
I might be a redneck man because it's
like they look like I think I have that
Vibe yeah you guys I love the same stuff
yeah catfish yeah yeah you like eating
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah in
fact I kind of run Aggie dude you know
but I go out there and I go and I love
them it's like we hugged dude I can feel
their bony bodies against my body you
know you then bony dude oh yeah yeah
yeah well it's sharp anyway
um I gotta go eat something Bobby Lee
get the out of here dog dude happy
belated birthday man I love you too it's
a big year for love for you brother see
you later
all right buddy bye bye man I'm gonna
keep talking even though you're leaving
okay
yeah
I'm just gonna pretend you're here
[Music]
Cornerstone
oh but when I reached that ground I'll
share this piece of mind I found I can
feel it in my bones
[Music]